[Música]
liberar siete tortugas y un cóndor
cambio del mundo que dicen ustedes
puedes liberar siete tortugas y un
cóndor no cambió el mundo pero sí cambió
la vida de martín a
y la de muchos que han asumido el reto
de vivir la sostenibilidad
a martina la llevamos a que liberará
tortugas en una zona del país que es el
magdalena medio y les aseguro que el
mundo de martina cambió algunas de esas
tortugas vuelven al ecosistema unas
entran a la cadena alimenticia
posiblemente no todas sobrevivan pero
les aseguro que la conexión de martina
con el ecosistema y con nuestro planeta
está intacta y eso es lo que yo quiero
que generemos entre todos
al igual que martín a tuve la
oportunidad desde los 5 años de vivir
con mi abuelita una cantidad de
voluntariados sociales hace 34 años ella
fundó la una fundación en la comuna 1 de
la ciudad de medellín y tuve la
oportunidad de conocer muy de cerca
todas las realidades sociales del país
buscando generar esos cambios llevo con
un gran equipo de trabajo hace 11 años
estamos acompañando a las organizaciones
públicas y privadas a que asuman esa
ruta a que logren esa ruta hacia el
desarrollo sostenible hemos acompañado a
más de 1.000 organizaciones en muchos
sitios del país y en muchos sectores
buscando que cada vez su desempeño
social y ambiental sea un poquito mejor
y entre todos vamos construyendo un país
y planeta
pero nos quedaban muchas reflexiones de
todos estos procesos y una de ellas es
que definitivamente la sostenibilidad no
se cuenta en el tablero a muchos nos han
explicado la sostenibilidad la triple
cuenta y eso sigue siendo un cuento muy
enredado no les parece
la sostenibilidad no se puede contar en
el tablero la sostenibilidad la tenemos
que vivir y esa es la invitación que yo
les quiero hacer la sostenibilidad debe
ser un estilo de vida la tenemos que
llevar todos por dentro aunque ya hemos
acompañado empresas a que se certifiquen
a que sean muy exitosas en el procesos
de sostenibilidad le tomamos el adn a
muchos de estos empleados de las
compañías y todavía vemos cuando vemos
esa muestra en el microscopio que
todavía hay mucho adn social y ambiental
para trabajar ahí tenemos un gran reto
tuve la oportunidad en el 2013 de
participar en un encuentro mundial de
empresas con propósito empresas que no
queremos ser las mejores empresas del
mundo buscamos ser las mejores para el
mundo aprovechamos la fuerza de los
negocios para la transformación social y
ambiental somos empresas que tenemos que
ser rentables pero a su vez analizamos
cada año cuál fue nuestro impacto social
y nuestro impacto ambiental
en este encuentro en la ciudad de
boulder en el estado de colorado en los
eeuu los fundadores de este movimiento
nos planteaban una pregunta cómo vamos a
seguir para seguir cómo vamos a hacer
para sensibilizar a más personas y
empresas en el planeta actualmente este
tipo de empresas ya somos 1.800 todavía
tenemos muchísimos espacios por
conquista pero con ese reto
regresé al país en el 2013 y convoque un
equipo de 18 amigos empresarios
emprendedores del sector público sector
privado de los medios y creamos
una iniciativa y esta iniciativa tenía
que tener unos ingredientes para el
cambio unos ingredientes que nos
ayudarán a acelerar la ruta hacia la
sostenibilidad primero teníamos que
generar muchísima conciencia hemos
avanzado soy consciente de eso pero
todavía nos falta muchísimo
un fuerte llamado a la acción gran parte
de los colombianos decimos que
compraríamos y preferimos productos
amigables con el ambiente y las
comunidades pero al momento estar en la
góndola no lo hacemos entonces tenemos
una brecha todavía que trabajar un
tercer ingrediente es el ejemplo
queremos poner como ejemplo todas estas
prácticas que personas y organizaciones
están haciendo los que están haciendo
bien las cosas los tenemos que poner
como ejemplo y resaltar esas buenas
prácticas para que muchos sigamos
aprendiendo inspiración así como martina
quedó inspirada lo único que me faltó
fue pedirle permiso a la mamá de martina
pero aquí aprovechó y le pidió permiso
para poderla publicar aquí en la
presentación
gracias a la amarilla
con estos cuatro ingredientes nació
ciclo 7 una semana cargada de
experiencias para fortalecer y vivir la
sostenibilidad
en el planeta
nos dijo un ex ministro de costa rica en
la primera versión una semana al año
sería suficiente para vivir de esa
manera todo el año y contribuir así a la
sostenibilidad desde adentro por esto
ciclo 7 siempre se hará en la semana del
día de la tierra que es el 22 de abril
la ruta de sitio 7 arranca un sábado
donde invitamos a voluntarios de
iberoamérica a que liberemos animales a
que trabajemos alrededor de la
biodiversidad con un gran grupo de
voluntarios hemos liberado más de 600
animales regresando los a su hábitat
natural
el segundo día de este sitio invitamos a
las familias es un domingo siempre será
un domingo el segundo día invitamos a
las familias a que vivamos la
sostenibilidad a que salgamos a las
calles a vivir una caravana de movilidad
sostenible y la rematamos en un parque
natural en muchas ciudades de
iberoamérica para que juntos disfrutemos
y vivamos los parques el tercer día nos
enfocamos en los estudiantes más de 250
líderes de la educación en iberoamérica
han aceptado este reto y estamos
invitando a que en todos los colegios y
universidades de iberoamérica podamos
seguir alineando nos durante esta semana
para entrenarnos y fortalecer la ruta
hacia el desarrollo sostenible el cuarto
día nos enfocamos en los creadores todos
los que tienen la posibilidad de
desarrollar productos y servicios
si los pensáramos desde el inicio
podríamos reducir una cantidad de
materiales
podríamos reciclar después cuando el
producto no se use entonces tenemos un
día donde más de 1200 diseñadores de
iberoamérica nos han compartido sus
trabajos y seguiremos en esta ruta
trabajando con todas las personas
creativas que quieren aportar desde el
diseño desde la creación de los
productos
el quinto día está enfocado en las
organizaciones como les decía ahora
tenemos que fortalecer la cultura de
sostenibilidad
aquí reunimos alrededor de 500 líderes
de sostenibilidad de las empresas
buscando que tengan las mejores
prácticas hacia la sostenibilidad
organizacional el sexto día la ruta nos
lleva hacia los estilos de vida
saludable porque la sostenibilidad
empieza por cada uno de nosotros estilos
de vida saludable que nos van a ayudar a
trabajar primero en nuestra
sostenibilidad personal no tendremos
organizaciones y ciudades sostenibles si
la sostenibilidad primero no la trabaja
cada uno de nosotros
el séptimo día termina ciclo 7 y
buscamos a través del arte y la cultura
llegar a muchos públicos que todavía nos
quedan faltando
les quiero mostrar un vídeo de cómo se
vivió ciclo 7 en la segunda versión que
la tuvimos en abril de este año
[Música]
ciclo 7 es una iniciativa que asumió el
reto de posicionarse como las olimpiadas
por la sostenibilidad en iberoamérica
con el desafío de mostrarle al mundo que
a través de diferentes experiencias se
puede generar conciencia y un fuerte
llamado a la acción que permita impactar
positivamente los ecosistemas de
iberoamérica las ciudades organizaciones
colegios universidades y todas las
personas interesadas en el desarrollo
sostenible esta es una causa que en 2016
movió a más de 22 países de iberoamérica
y llegó con su mensaje movilizador a más
de 9 millones de personas que
entendieron que las acciones pequeñas
son las que pueden generar los cambios
más grandes una semana que nos enseña
que es posible dejar un mundo mejor
para las generaciones futuras
siete días cargados de biodiversidad más
de 600 animales liberados en pero
américa o 'las tortugas cóndores entre
otros
movilidad sostenible tres mil personas
en la primera caravana de movilidad
sostenible
educación 250 líderes de 20
instituciones educativas
diseño sostenible una app ganadora
comprometida con proteger los océanos
expo sostenibilidad más de 500 líderes
trabajando por organizaciones
sostenibles
estilo de vida saludable más de 50 mil
consumidores responsables
[Música]
cultura más de 5000 personas disfrutando
de la sostenibilidad
o iberoamérica está conectada por una
misión generar conciencia nuestro reto
es sumar cada vez más aliados suman el
ciclo 7
[Música]
me retaron a contar esta historia sin
incluir el vídeo en 7 minutos yo lo reto
a usted a todos ustedes en iberoamérica
a vivir la sostenibilidad 24/7
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]